david mack malène merci de nous
accueillir
on a l'impression que vous êtes comme
sorte prison dans votre esprit
ce temps d'accrocher ses patins de plier
son tablier puis de passer à autre chose
yatuu des éléments qui ont pesé plus que
d'autres bon la pandémie est ce que
c'est un facteur c'est sur la pandémie à
[Musique]
l'après pandémie était pire que la
pandémie à ce qu'on essaie de les brûler
et le manque d'employés après la
pandémie c'était
comme un coup de grâce c'est parce qu'on
avait une légère
un coup la pandémie fini on est tous de
vacciner toute votre défiera normal
pinord c'est pire qu'à la pandémie parce
qu au moins pendant la pandémie on était
quelques employés mais on arrive à
travailler faire la fin nous ouvrir un
restaurant 100 plongeurs 100 serveurs
accueil manque trois cuisiniers pour
faire ces chiffres qu'on a finalement
droit de faire des chiffres mais on peut
pas faire des chiffres parce qu'il ya
personne puis c'est aussi le brent reste
l'élément intellectuelle de cette
brigade au restaurant à qui est là
depuis des années que tout à coup on
sait plus où personne et s'est
construit pas un grand restaurant une
semaine et comment règle ça il ya eu il
ya deux semaines la controverse du
salaire minimum chez picard il ya eu
comment on règle ça d'après d'après vous
ça va être pour quelqu'un d'autre à
régler je pense que je me suis battu
play et j'ai travaillé à coeur plein
comme un ambassadeur de la cuisine pour
montréal âge une très belle carrière je
suis
content d'être capable de finir ma
carrière en santé quoique ce soit à
saint quentin
mais il reste des des batailles à à être
être fait c'est quoi les miennes non je
comprends mais donnez nous une idée de
comment on peut régler c'est parce que
tous les restaurateurs parle de ce
problème d'aller chercher de la maine
est ce que c'est en payant mieux les
gens est ce que c'est en revoyant le
modèle on peut payer mieux les gens n'y
a pas de problème à payer mieux les gens
mais faut que les clients soient avertis
qu on la sait quand j'ai commencé à
cuisiner il ya plusieurs années ont
capoté quand on servait d'épreuve
principal à 22 dollars à 25 $ pilotes et
quand je dormais de mes années 30 on a
franchi le 35,40 dollars pour le plat
principal
puis là aujourd'hui on regarde on
s'envole dans les laisses tu es 425
dollars les spaghettis au marais 120 ha
les foies gras 75 dollars c'est sa voix
fait nehru et en france on y va on y
arrive mais à un moment donné les
clients il n'y a pas de faire quoi
dans ces restaurants haut de gamme à qui
promouvoit le tourisme montréal
peut-être taxe prêt qui a peut-être
beaucoup de ces restera là on pourrait
quasiment à faire l'application pour
commander des cadres de caoutchouc
ground work grenade s'est il ya un an
restera mais apprécié un restaurant
d'envergure théâtrale d'envergure
artistique d'envergure qu'on en fait pas
juste le strict minimum de servir agents
aux gens à manger on fait beaucoup plus
c'est un c'est une taxe peut-être ou à
un bénéfice de la culture t martin
picard a peut-être le droit d'être il ya
même beaucoup de gens de l'extérieur du
québec à l'intérieur du québec ont
imaginé des manières d'aider des
institutions des endroits qui sont
devenus des piliers de la restauration
m'aurait peut-être parce qu'aujourd'hui
si on paye pour les chorégraphies les
cartes de crédit on paye pour aller à
bhl puis os sarthois les systèmes de
réservation ou buried hors d'âge toutes
ces affaires là petit ont rendu qu'un
restaurant peut-être hyper bien géré ou
ce qu'on compte et on fait des
inventaires à tous les jours quand tu es
dans le 4 4 % 3 % ça étonne les gens qui
se disent déjà y passe aujourd'hui vous
roulez sur l'or vous l'argent vous avez
fait dans votre vie ce parce que j'avais
eu beaucoup de restaurants 4,5 je vous
dire si des cycles et joe beef à un peu
de succès les restaurateurs que vous
allez voir qu'ils prennent des retraites
en général qu'un peu de succès sont
souvent les propriétaires de leurs murs
qui sont propriétaires de leur immeuble
qui ont acheté des immeubles dans des
quartiers à qu'il ya plusieurs années et
ont oeuvré en tant que restaurant
pendant 20 ans et qui peuvent prendre
une retraite à l'aise à la campagne
parce qu'ils y ont vendu leurs murs
comme vous mais souvent on voit des
restaurants qui arrive qui ont travaillé
pendant 15 ans big lots le propriétaire
de l'immeuble double loyer on a commencé
à payer 5000 dollars de loyer
quinze ans plus tard c'est rendu 20
mille dollars de loyer puis
éventuellement ça marche plus donc
contrairement à ce qu'on pourrait croire
des boucs joe beef où on ne peut pas
avoir deux tables face jeu combien de
temps probante à maintenant c'est normal
non mais avant avant la pandémie c'est
sûr que c'est les réservations ouvrent
et
deux mois al avance bon ton était play
ce jour l'argent rendent pas à pleine
porte non non c'est se prend à 140
employés pour faire vingt mille dollars
de ventes ni vin c'est beaucoup de
personnel est un groupe pro a c'est un
food cost énorme surtout quand on
pratique les protéines de qualité du
boeuf de qualité aux vents du homard de
la pétanque le flétan à
celle fortune puis il faut pas oublier
qu'on paie le même prix que les
américains aient souvent les poissons du
québec et les poissons des maritimes les
pêcheurs préfèrent vendre aux états unis
parce que guyot est dangereuse de leur
compte de banque voyez ce que je veux
dire
un fils est acquis et 35 $ à montréal
des fois et 45 dollars à new york et
houston le même flux tendu bateau il ya
non
pourquoi
c'est devenu des adresses ci reconnu on
pense évidemment l'image de barack obama
et de monsieur trudeau dans votre
restaurant pour qu est ce que vous avez
eu comme recettes
comme baguette magique qui affectait
devenus des lieux importants pour moi
c'est comme la tempête parfaite à
frédéric morel est un grand cuisinier
mon associé qui demeurent en place au
restaurant qui est encore motivé qui
veulent encore travailler à frédéric est
un des grands cuisiniers qui avait un
bon cheminement j'avais un bon
cheminement pareil à on s'est retrouvé à
ce moment là il y avait pas eu beaucoup
de restaurants des petits restaurants
chef propriétaire s'était pas quelque
chose qui existait il ya 16 ans 17 ans
fait que tête frédéric et moi à ce
moment là on était peut-être
surqualifiés pour avoir un restaurant de
25 places pour nous faire 25 clients il
ya 16 ans chez joe beef avec nos
expériences et
notre savoir faire de la cuisine
française
c'était facile pour nous on hamm est
ainsi c'est le client un parent temps
qu'ils rentraient dans la porte on
faisait 25 client peut regretter que
facilement capable de garantir qu'on
allait complètement les éclater qu'on a
fait ça pendant plusieurs années jusqu'à
temps que les américains sans s'en
rendre compte jusqu'à temps qu'on s'est
fait offrir un livre d'écrire un livre
d'une maison de publications américaines
à pied à ce moment là c'est sûr qu'on a
commencé à sonder article en asie on
s'est ramassé sur la liste des 100
meilleurs restaurants je pense à 95 ou
size puis là c'était et un restaurant 40
places qui te plaît
question je vous ai je voulais vous
demander ce truc do fuba maillon pays
sont pas partis
en plus c'était la facture était sale et
parce qu'il a fallu bloquer des tablées
fallu mettre personne au bar je gagne
fallu nourrir ses coutures mais c'est
tout mais je me suis rendu compte après
la pandémie que j'avais 50 ans et aussi
comme une sorte de farce comme une joke
que je dis depuis des années en cuisine
j'ai tout te parler d' arrêter à 50 ans
je pensais pas que j'allais le faire
mais je le fais c'était cette espèce le
que j'arrête là où je continue par la
disa parce que le climat cuisine vous
raconter dans un article vous êtes allé
en france goulet
vous êtes arrivé dans l'ouest américain
puisse être douce et plus ce mot on et
comment il sait ce qu'on peut être
calmer est-ce qu'on peut être équilibré
mais un sens de l'urgence en
restauration ok il peut être cent vingt
personnes qui viennent manger à cette
heure il ya dix entrées 10 plein
principal à choisir l'équipe avec plus
toutes les tout les petits détails
ok mais aussi il faut se souvenir que on
a une permission spéciale à
on prend pas à la légère la permission
d'un être humain de nous laisser et
réduire plusieurs éléments protéines ou
carbohydrates ou légumes à l'intérieur
de leur corps il ya une certaine rigueur
de la restauration professionnelle de me
donner la permission ce soir allez à me
laisser introduire des huîtres du saumon
cru du foie gras des asperges du caviar
de la volaille du lapin mi cuit à
l'intérieur de votre corps c'est une
c'est une responsabilité que cuisinier
peut pas prendre à la légère lionel
rigueur professionnelle en cuisine haut
de gamme qui s'apprend
malheureusement d'une façon je veux pas
dire agressif mais
c'est important que le travail soit
hygiénique bien fait et que la rigueur
soit y compris par tout le monde qui est
même un certain climat de peur parce que
c'est important que tout le monde dans
la cuisine comprennent qu'on a on est en
très net roduit des aliments à
l'intérieur des gens le village
hâtivement possible avec les employés
mais vous êtes faut qu'un discipline
doucement avec un câlin
jeudi le jeune s'il te plaît
veille ta mise en place c'est
inacceptable dare-dare il ya dix ans
selon se faisait hurler après mais on se
rend compte que parce que les jeunes
acceptent de se faire de ces disciplines
oui oui parce que la manière de le faire
c'est moins qu'en cas que j'ai commencé
en restauration peut être la manière
était plus archaïque vas-y parquet oui
là vous allez allez sur vos terres
cultivées vous revenir aux sources en
amont de ce qu'il ya dans la cuisine on
pratique la viticulture à cet art marc
adam divine effet rob des hybrides on
pratique aussi
on a des poiriers des pommiers des
pruniers a fait que moi il ya du travail
à faire puis cesser de travailler
beaucoup et pareil un peu comme la
restauration s'est loupé c'est dur puis
dans trois quatre ans vous allez revenir
peut-être un projet de restaurant
on est fier qu'aux montréalais
que vous soyez vous avez fait ce que
vous avez fait je dis merci d'un pauvre
hère merci c'est moi qui vous remercie